yo what's up everybody procedure me
either way you back side of the witcher
3 with a another video on how to get
infinite money or just some quick money
fast if you needed to buy something so
this is going to be using the monster
nest exploit which is an exploit I've
done a video on previously however this
video is going to be mainly about a
specific monster nest that you can get
sea shells from that is located in the
south of valid I'm just showing you this
specific one you can see um where I'm at
right now it's kind of all right it's
the very south of Ellen it's around come
to the east of the that island with the
big tower on it and it's a little to the
north east of a lens grove I think
that's what it's called and you go here
you beat all the monsters if you don't
know they exploit this is it you go to
the monster nest you blow it up and then
you lose everything in the monster nest
except for one item you look away from
the monster nest so it's off screen and
then you can redo everything and you
have to make sure to leave one item in
it now you'll see I'm getting a lot of
seashells I'm only going for the sea
shells because seashells you can take to
a blacksmith's you can have license
break them and then you have pearls and
black pearls and you can sell those for
crazy amounts of money so that's
basically the video i just want to show
you guys the best monster nests you can
find you can get two three shells like
every basically like half second if you
do it fast enough so we hope you guys
have enjoyed this i know it was quick it
was sure it was just little location
guide soap you guys check out my other
videos if you like which your content is
i have a lot of stuff like that and yeah
see you all later peace out